mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünschte ihnen viel vergnügen
ein 14-jähriger gibt gas leonard riesen
rettet altgedientes und leitet bereits
sein zweites museum
vor drei jahren gewann sie den concours
géza anda wieder sieg ihre karriere
beflügelt
[Musik]
wie werden wir in zukunft zusammen sehen
dieser frage geht die
architekturbiennale venedig nach und wie
können wir besser loslassen
ein festival saft im tod hallo wir
kommen auf den kulturplatz ja wir machen
heute stationen hier in murten das
schmucke städtchen ist eine reise wert
und hier treffe ich gleich den jüngsten
museumsdirektor der schweiz
leonard riesen ist gerade mal 14 aber
ein echter experte
ich freue mich sind sie mit dabei das
malerische murten mit seiner intakten
altstadt geschützt über jahrhunderte
dank der historischen ringmauer ein
wahres bio ja murten zelt 12 türme dazu
gehört auch dass bernd uhr ganz oben die
uhr
die gewichts steine kanonenkugeln ein
relikt aus der schlacht bei murten
wahrhaft geschichtsträchtig dieser ort
die häuser der altstadt sind getreu
einer vorschrift bewohnt damit das
mittelalterliche städtchen lebendig
bleibt ja wie wir in zukunft zusammen
leben werden mit pandemie mit
klimawandel und mit überbevölkerung mit
diesen fragen beschäftigt sich aktuell
die architekturbiennale in venedig
[Musik]
nach der zwangspause endlich wieder eine
fahrt mit dem vaporetto wegen der
pandemie findet die architektur biennale
mit einem jahr verspätung statt
venedig ist nach wie vor eigentlich leer
die naheliegende frage meistert die
menschheit corona wird in der
ausstellung natürlich nicht gestellt
dafür eine ebenso drängende mit
universellem ausmaß wie werden wir
zusammenleben kann es darauf überhaupt
konkrete brauchbare antworten geben da
ist irgendwie alles drin öffentlich
privat die großen themen migration klima
wohl krise also für mich ist es in so
über breit gefasstes eigentlich vages
motto alle petersen kritiker der
schweizer architekturzeitschrift
hochparterre geht mit verhaltenen
erwartungen ins a finale
dabei startet die hauptausstellung mit
provokativen thesen menschen müssten zu
humanoiden werden um die globalen
herausforderungen klima und
überbevölkerung zu bewältigen
in lebensräumen die eigentümlich corona
tauglich sind
mehr kunst als architektur der kritiker
ist überrascht sucht das gespräch
etwa mit diesem öko planer der
zusammenleben und künftige
nahrungsaufnahme gestalten will
dies ist ein vertikaler garten der sich
ganz einfach in die flächen unserer
gebäude anpassen kann
mit hochintensiven effizienten
mikroorganismen kulturen
jeder dieser bakterien reaktoren kann
genug proteine erzeugen um eine
vierköpfige familie zu ernähren
bakterien die mittels photosynthese
protein ausscheiden klingt nach
astronautennahrung und überzeugt unseren
begleitern nicht gerade
architektonisch konkreter wird der
genfer leopold bianchini mit seinen
sphären konstruktionen oder der franzose
nikola lesny mit seinen luftigen
hochhäusern neue formen des
zusammenlebens bietet auch diese
konstruktion aus glas und carbonfaser
peterson ist am beitrag aus deutschland
offensichtlich interessiert die
stuttgarter werben mit dem motto aus
weniger wird mehr was wir hier zeigen
ist eigentlich gerne ausbauen können das
nur neun kilogramm pro quadratmeter
wiegt mit ganz wenig material das vor
ort gefertigt werden kann und daraus
eigentlich ein gebäude der zukunft steht
dazu gleich nebenan digitales bauen
durch das forschungsteam kremation cola
der eth zürich
roboter fertigen vollautomatisch
stahlgitter und füllen diese dann mit
beton auf im gespräch die patterson
allen eine chance will nicht
voreingenommen seien
manchmal verlieren sie also man ist
interessiert dann sprechen wir mit
jemand merkt okay das jetzt eher eine
luftnummer und ein anderes mal ist man
vielleicht skeptisch und einer kann
überzeugen dass das jetzt wirklich
interessant ist nicht alles erschließt
sich auf den ersten blick
man spürt auf der diesjährigen
architekturbiennale stellensuchender aus
die die brennenden fragen unserer zeit
als ausgangspunkt nehmen
ganz im sinne von kurator kaczynskis
normalerweise werden diese fragen
wichtig wenn wir unzufrieden sind mit
unserer art des zusammenlebens
wenn wir unzufrieden sind mit unserem
politischen system dann suchen wir nach
antworten nach inspirationen um uns
herum
deshalb dachte ich es sei zeit für die
architektur neue alternative lebensarten
vorzuschlagen
[Musik]
die biennale ein sammelsurium von
vorschlägen
vielleicht setzen die teilnehmerländer
in den giardini eigene architektonische
akzente im schweizer pavillon greifen
genfer architekten und kunstschaffende
das thema grenz erfahrungen auf und
fragen wie wirken sich grenzen auf das
zusammenleben aus dabei können grenzen
und grenzsteine auch mitten durchs land
verlaufen
da wird vorschlagen dass man aus gramzow
uhr geht das und peripherie beachtet und
das nicht nur eine geografische sind
sondern auch in eine soziologische
singen das heißt dass nicht wenige
zentrale stimme beantwortete keine
zukunft sondern dass es zum bad in
kooperation im osten viel steht eine
vielstimmige dialog um buttersäure das
engagement in den länderpavillons stimmt
redaktor peterson wieder versöhnlicher
auch wenn die biennale sich in der
motivsuche insgesamt etwas verirrt
das nominale einen baukasten gibt um
sich die bessere welt von morgen zu
bauen dass das wäre naiv und das wäre
auch wahrscheinlich keine gute idee aber
ich meine wenn er sagt how to lift zu
geben verspricht man sich ja antworten
und nicht fragen und möglichst auch
konkrete antworten paar und sehr aktiv
ist
viele fragezeichen also auf dieser
biennale im jahr eins nach der pandemie
zusammenleben bleibt eine
bewährungsprobe
zumindest diese antwort dürfen alle aus
venedig mit nach hause nehmen
wir sind zurück in murten und jetzt
wollen wir eintauchen ins universum von
leonard riesen der jüngste
museumsdirektor der schweiz
hier im alten lok der pool murken zeigt
der raritäten rund um technik verkehr
und geschichte
[Musik]
und hier fragt sich schon hier mit
system und das ist eigentlich alok modi
dampf zweimal blut und wurde aus klein
geboten
[Musik]
hier wird die dogan ist hier zählt das
ist sehr speziell
das ist ein so genanntes what to say
classics auto und das ist boden in 216
zu einer schülerin und und daher denke
ich jetzt gymnasium sondern im tor
das ist motor von münster 106 liter auto
und da schaue immer dürftig sieht ein
scheich verunfallt und dazu sich ein
alter worten hat da keinen unterschied
genau weil sie schon sehr interessant
das system vor dem router und 1900 mhz
rausgegangen und eine ist auf die
buchstaben auch selbst st
dieses b genau wo hast du aktiv
man wisse jetzt schon die frage also
dass ich mit der typische so oder über
fachbücher tut mir das nachlasse und
damit die züge an motiven alternativer
gut mit dem alter und die müssen nach
einer view sehr interessant die sache
[Musik]
das ist mir nicht so sein
das wird unsere bedingung ist natürlich
studie wird öl gehört nur mir so schön
der hirschstraße und leider verschrottet
was ist dein gesicht vor dem grand was
hat das frieren für das lucky
aufgestellt oder nimmt zu sagt sie
verbrauchten in ski out für die ganz
verschiedene transportfähig sind einmal
beim häftling aus wächst so unter der
ladefläche sehen
für ausflüge mit der häftlinge englisch
englisch im jahr ist ja ausflug macht
genau und als sie sich mit einem profi-
oder schufa gefahren dort ausgelassen
dort mit der analyse der abläufe und
dort seinen geschäftspartnern um
mitternacht
ihr altes bewahren und pflegen sowie das
leonard tut das ist das eine
loslassen können das ist das andere und
dazu gehört auch der abschied gehört der
tod mit dazu wir alle wissen darum und
sind doch meister im verdrängen und
genau hier setzt das festival hallo tod
an und will dieses unausweichliche thema
mehr in unser leben bringen
bunt und lebendig kommt es daher aber
auch ernst und tiefgründig das
schweizweit erste interdisziplinäre
kulturfestival hallo tod lädt mit über
50 projekten dazu ein dem lebensende
unbeschwerter zu begegnen und das an
verschiedenen orten mitten in zürich
eine idee die vor der pandemie
entstanden ist wie zwei der fünf
initiantinnen betonen jetzt aber brauche
es erst recht kreative zugänge zur
vergänglichkeit in sie und andere sieht
sich wirklich der tod ist immer da und
meistens sagen regimetreue und zeigt sie
sollen 3
das hat dass eine pandemie zeigt die
todes präsenter wurde aber darüber
erfolgt also immer einen schwarzmarkt
dasselbe wenn es dann wirklich so ist
dass sie tot vor der türe steht
schwierig aber es ist ehrlich mutig und
das tut im nachhinein
das tabu brechen auf vielfältige weise
dazu lädt das festival ein
zum beispiel kann man in einem sarg
probeliegen in diesem rahmen bietet
christiane gräber gespräche an
auf das man sich dem eigenen tod
annähern kann christiane gräber stellt
am sarg fragen zum leben was ist ihnen
wichtig worüber lachen sie was soll man
ihnen nachrufen
die 60 jährige kennt sich mit dem thema
sterben aus
die ehemalige schulleiterin schreibt
beruflich abschiedsreden für
beerdigungen und sie weiß es wird viel
gelogen weil trauerreden
dabei gehören nicht nur das harmonische
hinein es muss hinein
kleine anekdoten über die man im
rückblick lachen kann und es muss in die
ecken und kanten seitdem ich diesen
beruf mache ist das leben viel wichtiger
das leben ist so es ist mir so deutlich
immer häufiger ist es endlich also muss
man doch zurück zum sarg die mutige
probe liegen ließ sich von anfänglichen
bedenken nicht abschrecken
ich spüre schon so was mit mir gemacht
aber es hat gar nicht als arrangeur von
negativen gefühlen aber eigentlich gar
nicht da sind wir in uster ist nicht
irgendwer
jetzt könnte man stundenlang spielen
das festival findet analog aber auch
digital statt den filmtod seien zum
beispiel kann man streamen wenn man sich
auf verblüffende gespräche über den tod
und absurd das einlassen will
die meisten veranstaltungen werden
bewusst nicht an schauplätzen
durchgeführt die an sterben erinnern
eine ausnahme eine pietätvolle
installation im alten krematorium beim
friedhof sihlfeld die performance nur
wer von eva wandeler wird auf
bildschirmen zu sehen sein
mit ihrem körper zeichnet die künstlerin
bilder auf tücher ein poetischer
ausdruck des sterbens und entschwinden
[Musik]
zwischen vor dem transfer bereich
vielleicht zukunft ermögliche zukunft
ganz offen gibt es die rwa haben das
ungewisse und das unausweichliche des
todes wird mit dem älterwerden präsenter
davon erzählt der festivalbeitrag des
tanztheaters dritter frühling letzte
dinge ist ein berührendes stück über das
verschwinden und das loslassen des
lebens die auseinandersetzung mit dem
tod mac hört was die ältere lüth für
einige der zur hand oder für gefühl und
für erfahrungen zum thema schaffe
beieinander natürlich irgendwie und
nimmt ihm der schreck verlor die
tänzerische beschäftigung mit dem tod
entlastet
also für mich ist ganz klar das sieht
jetzt ist zu dass boni wir machen jetzt
machen wir so weiter die schöne sache
noch das von ihr verpflichtung zum
erfüllen wie wilfried dass mir hängt das
böse gerechnet
hilft einfach kabine vom tod so die
auseinandersetzung auf die art es wird
das festival hallo tot
inspiriert dazu über vergänglichkeit und
damit über das eigene dasein
nachzudenken
seine zeit intensiv zu nutzen und das
leben zu feiern
[Musik]
große lieder schafft für sammler für die
alten sachen gibt es das etwas wie eine
initialzündung im labor sogar zu ende
geht es nicht aber ich schon so zu
führen habe ich zb mit munteren und
flohmarkt sind und dadurch sehen die
kontakte mit den sachen kapitals
herzlicher geschlagen ja das ist so
wie erklärst du dir dass du als junger
mann so große freud seine große passion
als oder alte sachen ja es ist sicher so
der autor technik ein und sagen dass sie
recht mit viel wertigkeit und qualität
sie gemacht wurden und das ist meistens
europa immer wieder zum laufen bringt
sich sehen motor oder gegen das man
sollte einfach reparieren und das nur
gemerkt wie sich die lücken käufer
dieser wirkt gut machen
ja hallo sage dass ich bereits das
zweite museum du bist tot luther
museumsdirektors erste kleine museum
ältere angerichtet ja das ist richtig
das erdgeschoss wo ich noch nicht so
viel
ich brauchte genau und typisch artikel
stimmt das ja sei also nur ein team juni
ab 10
was haben 14 ist eine komische literatur
mittag von vitogaz technik sparen sie
dazu ja also die finger das spezielle
aber interessant ist
beim mini kollegen einmal kam ein
geschoss bitte ganze ja ein türöffner in
der klassischen musik das ist
zweifelsohne der parcours gesa under in
zürich wer richtig meisterhaft klavier
spielt kann dort eine sagenhafte
karriere starten
ja und morgen da läuft er wieder der
concours géza anda vor drei jahren haben
wir diesen wettbewerb ganz hautnah
begleitet und konnten damals der
strahlenden siegerin clancy gratulieren
ja und heute zeigen wir ihnen wie dieser
preis ihre karriere befeuert hat
klar wann sie ist zurück am zürcher
musikkonservatorium diese seele und die
virtuosen eine art liebesbeziehung etwas
wie ein heiliger ort jetzt für mich weil
das erste mal wenn ich hier war das war
für die wettbewerbe der concours géza
anda gehört zu den wichtigsten
nachwuchswettbewerben für pianistinnen
ein internationales teilnehmerfeld
stellt sich den immensen anforderungen
verlangt wird ein umfangreiches
repertoire
[Musik]
clancy aus den usa mit wurzeln in china
gehörte vor drei jahren zu den
favoritinnen
das war für mich nicht nur ein ziel aber
vielleicht ein traum ich dachte mir
jetzt bin ich 28 und ich wollte
unbedingt auch zeigen was ich gelernt
habe schon in der vorausscheidung hatte
sie überzeugt das finale mit orchester
auch das eine besonderheit des concours
géza anda wurde vollends zum triumph
ich fange gleich oben an und sage ladies
first der erste preis geht an wo angst
das gute war für mich das war schon
ziemlich im geschäft kann man quasi
sagen ich habe schon ziemlich viel
gespielt besonders in die
deutschsprachige länder also das gas
ankommt
die haben natürlich viel türe geöffnet
dazu ein preisgeld von 30.000 franken
und drei jahre concert management durch
die gesa under stiftung klar wann sie
hat früh gelernt sich selbst zu
vertrauen ging mit 17 alleine nach
deutschland
dank des wettbewerbssiegers wird sie an
größere konzerthäuser geladen spielt mit
renommierten musiker innen
ja ich spiele inzwischen jetzt ziemlich
viel in schöne seele in deutschland
ermisch hatte mehrmals jetzt die münze
in elbphilharmonie aufzutreten und das
ist für ich glaube jeder künstler und
jung oder sehr gut
eine große ehre habe ich war auch in die
große zahl ich habe ein wessi tal
gegeben und das war natürlich ganz
besonders
ihr gegenüber ebenfalls ein ehemaliger
gewinner des concours géza anda alexei
volodin mitglied der jury 2018 bei
lanxess sieg nur etwas fehlte der
applaus
natürlich war das mitten in lockt zwar
ziemlich leer aber trotzdem so eine
erinnerung weg ist man nun soll es aber
endlich wieder losgehen mit auftritten
vor publikum winterthur ist gut die
nächste saison habe ich schon in japan
und ich werde wieder in china gehen
ich habe sogar konzert mit bucher in
orchester sind solche ganz bekannt
natürlich und ich spiele jetzt auch
ziemlich viel in usa auch und ja
natürlich ich warte ganz spannend auf an
den tag wo wir wieder in ein großes
risiko zusammen machen könnte mit großem
orchester ohne diese abstand ohne masken
das ist wirklich wie ein traum
zum schluss eine frage die uns brennend
interessiert
was ist das geheimnis ihres
ausserordentlichen klavierspiels
für uns aus musikern nach bestimmte
jahre haben wir vielleicht weniger
probleme mit die technische sache so es
gibt nicht mehr um das jeden tag müssen
wir was finger übungen machen
das ist einfach mehr die
lebenserfahrungen zusammen
ich kriege immer so viel einfach von
reisen oder von museen zu besuchen
besondere ausstellungen wenn man ein
sehr schönes kunstwerk sieht es kommt
diese gefühl das kriegt man nur wenn man
lebt also wirklich med
[Musik]
stinkt den großen ist es schön
ich bin gespannt was man für alles
leonard riesen mit 14 ein doppelter
museumsdirektor und schön waren sie mit
der wahl hier auf unserem ausflug nach
murten nächste woche sehen wir uns in
zürich wieder und dann zeigen wir ihnen
kunst in ganz ungewohntem rahmen die auf
sf1 geht es gleich weiter mit der serie
die wege des herrn
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen der kultur
swisslos